the show was about to begin I hope
everybody has a good time enjoy the show
see you later good evening ladies and
gentlemen and Hilary Swank Spirit Award
for tonight's performance the role of
hosts normally played by Illeana Douglas
will be played by jennifer Tilly during
the show there will be no flash
photography in fact there will be no
flashing of any kind and that means you
do drew Barrymore without further ado
please welcome your talented funny and
very very sexy host me jennifer Tilly
[Music]
hi everybody welcome to spirit Saturday
as we call it here in Santa Monica
I'm your host Jennifer Tilly
call me Jen I must say I was very
excited when Diane our producer blurted
out in a moment of desperation that she
had lost her host and she asked me to
fill in I said I was pleased and
flattered that when you think of the
Spirit Awards the first person you think
of is jennifer Tilly and diana said no
no the first person she thought of was
John Waters and then Kevin Spacey and
then Samuel Jackson Janeane Garofalo Ben
Affleck Lisa Kudrow
buck Henry who hung up on her apparently
nobody was up for the much-coveted job
of Spirit Award host I was actually
number nine on the list
I was about to angrily decline when I
suddenly remembered Illeana Douglas had
gotten a third page three paragraphs
story and variety lovingly detailing her
indie career complete with a full-color
photo my career could use that kind of
publicity I decided I spend many happy
hours on the phone with my publicist
rearranging my bio to make it look more
important
taking out goosed Berta pray house
arrest
adding Sophie's Choice breaking the
waves we spent a day alone arguing about
which photo makes me look younger I was
saying we should use the heavily
retouched one because I spent a lot of
money on back Carol said why don't we
just use the picture which you shot five
years ago you know the one where you
have the really short hair okay so this
is what happened we finally got the
press packet out and I waited every day
I ran to my mailbox to see if variety or
The Hollywood Reporter had come with
that very thrilling exciting story about
me and nothing not a shred of press
apparently the substitute host is about
as newsworthy a Sally kirklands next
picture but oh don't boo me you've all
been there you're up you're down right
now I think I'm down I was ninth on the
list anyway that's not why we're here
today I'm here because I'm filled with
Indy spirit according to my manager
there are two kinds of movies he says
Jennifer there's two kinds of movies
there's major motion pictures and
there's major pains in the ass
today we are here to honor the pains in
the ass I'm proud of my Indian heritage
and in honor of the Spirit Awards I have
compiled a self-help list that I think
might be useful for all unified actors
out there today it's called how to tell
if you're in an independent film by
jennifer Tilly how to tell if you're in
an independent film joey Pantoliano
'he's name is above the title
three weeks after you wrap the producer
asked you if you can shoot some more
nude scenes you know so he can sell the
foreign Tori Spelling has a cameo Harvey
Keitel is naked you have to cross a
picket line to get to your trailer
whoops
you have no trailer the poster features
a hot chick who's not in the movie the
actors pay his favorite nations but
you're getting three hundred thousand
dollars to do your own makeup wink wink
and if you're confused by that last joke
you need to call your agent mm-hmm okay
clink-clink-clink here are the Spirit
Awards we do not indulge in Spirit Award
cliches okay oh all right I'll get me
back out up a little back it up a little
because I had something to say okay
we're not backing it up a little oh I
skipped a huge part okay one thing I
like about the Spirit Awards is that
they're so relaxed you can just roll out
of bed and come straight here if you're
a guy you don't have to shave if you're
a girl you don't have to brush your hair
if you're jennifer Tilly you don't have
to put on a $10,000 Gucci dress you just
do it because you want to
I can see weather days look in some of
your eyes that you have never been to an
award show before but don't worry I'm
going to tell you how to behave I'm
going to take you through it step by
step
here are the Spirit Awards we do not
have dull gin award show cliches we
don't look at the camera and tell their
kids they can go to bed now
we don't say I'd like to thank everybody
I ever met we just proceed to do so we
don't incorporate the fact that the
orchestra is playing us on into our
speech it's not cutesy it just fills
everybody with acute anxiety and makes
them anxious in fact here at the spirit
of words we don't even have an orchestra
we have a method that's almost equally
as effective I call it the method of
social ostracize ation listen closely if
a speech starts to approach the
five-minute mark feel free to pause and
shuffle your feet at ten minutes it's a
good time to rummage through your gift
bag see what you got maybe trade things
with your friends if it goes beyond 15
minutes it's perfectly appropriate to
get up and start milling around you know
smoothing trying to get that next job I
think David O Russell's table is right
over there one last word even though we
pride ourselves in being highly original
over the years I have noticed a few
spirit award cliches creeping in so this
year I hirabai declare a moratorium on
Harvey Weinstein jokes references to how
many you get now that you're a
director and stories about how you
finance your film by maxing out your
credit cards or giving blood frankly we
don't care these are now officially
India war cliches if you have
incorporated one of the above into your
speech please feel free to visit our
talented writer Robert Taylor who's
lurking around backstage and he'll be
happy to rewrite your joke free of
charge okay let's get started cuz we
have a fun show ahead of us
our first award is for the best debut
performance by an actor and actress our
presenters are both previous winners one
is taking a break from preparing for
SATs while last year's winner is
studying to be a doctor kind of shows
you what a huge career boost winning
this award is doesn't it anyway here is
Heather mock terrazzo and evan adams
[Music]
No do you want okay fine hi how you guys
done good Jennifer does look great
I'll get her later so um we're here to
present the Award for Best Debut
performance yes we are and it's a
wonderful honor I mean the the
Independent Spirit Award for Best Debut
performance I think shows the spirit of
the independent community independent
film community in that where else do you
get encouraged as a young or emerging
artist so it's very exciting to be here
today do you remember when you won 97
hmm what was it like horrible why
very scary all right we don't think
about winning or I didn't think about
winning that's for sure very true and
the nominees for Best Debut performance
are Kimberly J Browne for tumbleweeds
Jessica Campbell for election
J Gordon for sugar town
Toby Smith for dry long zone and Chris
Stafford for edge of 17 and the
Independent Spirit Award goes to
Kimberly J Browne
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh I had such a wonderful time
making this film it's truly one of the
most one of those experiences that you
will never forget and first of all I'd
like to thank my Heavenly Father because
without him I wouldn't have he just he
gave me this great opportunity to do
what I love and my parents because they
were so many hats and do so much for me
that words cannot express how much I
love them so thank you
my very enormous large family my three
brothers Richard Roman and Dylan who
give up a lot to support me the Browns
the East losses and the gallops for
always being there special thanks to
Michael Katz Randi Ross Barbra Coleman
and Victoria kress
all my agents at UTA the wonderful great
people at fine line features and
everybody who works in the cast and crew
of tumbleweeds Angela Shelton who wrote
just the greatest character for me to
play and let me have so much with so
much fun with the characters so thank
you Angela Jo Sanders who taught me a
lot
Janet McTeer who I really really
seriously would not be up here if it
were not for her I had we had so much
fun together and thank you Janet cuz he
taught me a lot and you are just such an
amazing actress and last but not least
the O'Connor brothers Greg the producer
and Gavin with the director because if
it were not for Gavin I really really
would not be up here and
so thank you Gavin cuz I had a great
time making this film thank you thank
you
and now I'd like to introduce buck Henry
okay I'm sure he doesn't remember me but
I auditioned for Illeana Douglas is part
in to-die-for I just like follow her
around and try to pick up stuff that she
doesn't want to do but anyway there was
this really great monologue is about a
page and a half I was a little off that
day I improvised I think about
two-thirds of it and I felt really bad
because buck was there and I think he
was thinking I'm the great buck Henry
who is she to screw with my words okay I
felt bad about that so I really want to
give him a great introduction buck Henry
he's a man who's an international sex
symbol a fantastic actor a former host
of the Independent Spirit Awards a great
writer a great all-around guy fact he's
such a great writer I wish he had
written this introduction please welcome
the one and only buck Henry
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you very much I'm deeply
deeply moved I only wish the cameras
could pick up this four or five thousand
people standing many with tears
streaming down their cheeks I I've been
asked to give you an overview of what
this organization is about and the
philosophy behind it so please listen
carefully so I'm going to speak very
fast and it's not gonna make any sense
how did this all come about years ago in
a time before men and women were
measured by the number of hits on their
website a time when David Geffen and
Mike Eisner and Mike Ovitz were all
roughly the same height a time before
Ron bass single-handedly solved the
unemployed writer problem a time when
the names Harvey and Bob referred to a
couple of guys who detail your car a
time when Rex Reed actually bought his
CDs a small group of people gathered
together to form an organization that
would be cinematically groundbreaking
aesthetically thought-provoking but more
importantly tax-exempt the first problem
was what to call this organization
serendipitously one of the group's
founding members was in possession of
several thousand matchbook sand paper
napkins with a monogram of his home
states indiana fire patrol workers out
of this stroke of good fortune the IFP w
was born for a number of years it was my
high honor and I must say loathsome
responsibility to host this annual
ceremony that began its life in a
midtown restaurant whose specialty was
geographical availability and a general
lack of customers the event was an
immediate success why because in its
wisdom the Board of Directors guaranteed
a minimum of one award to anyone who
showed up because it was within easy
walking distance of La Cienega Boulevard
famed nude theater and because it only
lasted 40 minutes
such of course is not the case today
today we the if' peers no longer stand
in the shadow of the slew of award shows
that came before us like the Golden
Globes we too have on our staff men and
women who speak no readily identifiable
language like the Academy Awards we also
enjoy lengthy semi-coherent speeches on
the history of cinema of which this is I
believe a prime example and as for
unexpected drama
what other awards show can compare with
last year's unforgettable Best Actress
riveting unrehearsed onstage nervous
breakdown the independent film award is
recognized if not the world over at
least within a radius of several blocks
as a hallmark of artistic achievement
even though or perhaps because of the
fact that no shipment of these cunningly
designed trinkets has ever been hijacked
held for ransom were sold on eBay now
for the first time I have been
authorized to reveal the unique system
by which the winners of these awards are
chosen not for us the method of the
Motion Picture Academy whose votes are
controlled as you know by a large block
of senior citizens who live in the
Goldwyn theater and who it is rumored
inspired one of this year's memorable
movie lines I see dead people
nor is our technique that of the foreign
press who basically couldn't care less
who wins or loses because they know the
secret of faithful celebrity attendants
if you serve enough booze they will come
the IFP west on the other hand always
struggling to make ends meet realized
long ago that the winners names had to
be applied to their charming statuettes
and that the engraver charges by the
hour that is why the men and women with
the shortest names always win
now of course our ceremony is carried
coast-to-coast by not one but two two
esteemed television entities the
independent film channel which boasts
the world's most extensive collection of
Henry Jaglom features and Bravo Bravo
the station that informs the audience at
the start of every film that its
devotion to artistic integrity compels
it to edit out anything offensive to
anyone yes we have arrived and in order
to honor the independent filmmakers of
past and present
Peggy Rice key of the IFP West Board of
Directors has constructed the following
film which will educate amuse and
lighten and possibly remind us of our
own failures thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
all my favorite memories have been of
movies now first of all you're not
stupid
look I have trouble figuring out the tax
on checks so what yeah it's exactly
right it's out of Africa meets pretty
woman I'm not laughing at you I'm
laughing with you but I'm not laughing
[Music]
wait it's Jerry I we gotta talk it's
something hard jeez it's terrible
[Music]
well what were the movies oh this and
that
the only ones you may have heard of all
the Frankenstein movies Frankenstein and
Bride of Frankenstein and it's unnethe
and the other ones do no III just
directed the first two no no the others
were done by hacks
[Music]
for your information I'm bisexual
please I went to a Bar Mitzvah once that
doesn't make me Jewish
[Music]
it's also sharp we're gonna need a
bigger boat
[Music]
that was trippy Teri Garr and ripping
done
hi hi I can't believe it's been 15 years
since then that we did that we got the
first award did we get no word for this
we did I did you didn't oh I'm sorry but
that was a long time ago how you been
I'm fine I've been fine you know um I
think William Morris has me in the
actors protection program you know no
one can find me I'm very well hidden
it's great now are you here
no actually I'm doing them the Burt
Reynolds phase of my career you know I'm
doing game shows and then I'm gonna do
kind of a Boogie Nights thing and then
I'm gonna go right back to obscurity so
and what about you what do you think I
just did a movie entirely on TV I'm
sorry direct-to-video that's too bad no
no no no it's his very digital video
it's a very exciting revolutionary
medium it's gonna obliterate film as we
know it and audiences and soon everyone
will be able to make a movie everyone
think of that millions of directors more
and more directors speaking of very
exciting very calm down I'm very okay
let's let's give our award whatever the
hell it is okay no the nominee oh no
with you okay this is the nominees for
the best
first screenplay and they are Todd
Williams for Adventures of Sebastian
Cole
Charlie Kaufman for being John Malkovich
kimberly peirce and andy biñan four boys
don't cry
and rap for cookies fortune
and John Roach and Mary Sweeney for the
straight story
and the Spirit Award goes to Charlie
Kaufman for being John Milton
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thanks to Spike Jonze a great director
for a writer to work with an amazing
cast Catherine Keener Cameron Diaz John
Cusack Orson Bean Mary Kay plays Charlie
Sheen our producers Vince Landy Steve :
sandy Stern Michael Stipe our DP lance
acord editor Erickson Brennan our
production designer Kate Kate Barrett
just amazing people who worked really
hard and creatively and I don't know
what else
Oh John Malkovich whoo saving him for
last because I really didn't get I was
saving him for last because I want to
thank him for in addition to his
spectacular portrayal of John Malkovich
I I just I'm forever in his debt for his
sense of humor and his what I think is
his courage and being willing to be in
this movie
thank you very much
as you know this year we're celebrating
the 15th anniversary of the Independent
Spirit Awards but it is also the 20th
anniversary of the IFP West so what
exactly does IFP stand for nobody seems
to know some people say it stands for
insufficiently funded projects artisan
thinks it stands for irritatingly fuzzy
pictures I've even heard people say it
stands for I penguins but I think
that's sort of a fuzzy theory now to
explain what it really stands for is
somebody who should know it's the
executive director of IFP West dawn
Hudson
[Music]
thanks Jennifer IFP is a clumsy name for
an organization with the elegant mission
of nurturing and protecting the artists
in the film industry
the directors writers actors and
cinematographers who are willing to make
subversive provocative films that only
one person could make as opposed to
films made for and apparently by anybody
IFP West was created when the
independent film movement was hardly a
movement at all just a few filmmakers
around the country working in isolation
all that changed when Sandra Schulberg
called the first gathering of
independent filmmakers in New York and
one year later in 1980 filmmakers
Gregory Nava and Anna Thomas held a
similar meeting on the west coast they
wanted to see how many filmmakers in Los
Angeles wanted to make their own films
outside the soul-crushing machinery of
the studio system six people showed up
and now twenty years later we are 5,000
strong
we are able to help young talented
filmmakers and old talented filmmakers
in ways we never dreamed possible before
IFP West offers our members free
consultations with line producers free
casting rooms digital cameras at very
low rental rates free screening rooms
$60,000 in filmmaker grants and 150 free
screenings of independent films every
year this grows thank you it's a good
thing this growth would not have been
possible without the generosity of our
corporate sponsors who have worked hard
on our behalf
our friends at these companies have
spent hours and hours persuading their
bosses that yes it does make sense to
support tiny non-commercial films about
uplifting subjects like rape incest
sexual dysfunctions spousal abuse and
frogs so a special thanks to Nevada
watch and our friends Scott Woodward
Mary Claire Sullivan and Michelle Newman
from turning lead coastal reserve
vineyards lupus kalus Stephanie Gallo
and Fred Dugan from Sprint PCS rod egg
door Joe Edward and Brian Bailey and our
incredible premier sponsors from
Motorola David Penske and Jeffrey frost
from DLJ direct Blake Darcy Jill
Anderson and Bob flowers and from our
staunchest supporters through thick and
thin at entertainment weekly John
Squires Dave Morris fred nelson and
kathleen war they are also hosting yes
great their 10th year anniversary party
after the Spirit Awards to which you are
all invited and of course our longtime
companions and dear friends from the
independent film channel who are
sponsors and even better they put up
cold hard cash for boys don't cry so
please thank
thank you to Kathleen door Jonathan
staring and it Carol and thank you to
our spirit awards chair Peggy Rice key
our nominating committee chair Loy
Parker and a big thank you to our spirit
awards producer for the past six years
Dianna's on story and finally thank you
to my dear friend Marion schwendemann
and her colleague Michael Weiss they're
here from express and who's our fashion
partner for today in the year 2001 thank
you for dressing our beautiful FINA our
Uche it's back there who's handing out
the Spirit Awards and a big hand for
everybody
everyone here is supporting IFC West
independent filmmaking it's because of
you that we've grown so thank you now it
is my pleasure to introduce our next two
presenters for the best first feature
under $500,000 category here's a guy won
the Spirit Awards for playing banky in
chasing amy and the leading Latvian
Italian actress of our times in fact the
only Latvian Italian actress of our time
please welcome Jason Lee and Debby Mazur
[Applause]
[Music]
hi hello hi we're here to present the
award for best first feature under
$500,000 you know Jason I'd show you my
best feature but it's gonna cost you way
over five hundred thousand dollars man
that's not a lot
[Music]
so the nominees for Best first feature
under $500,000 are the Blair Witch
Project directed by Daniel Myrick and
Eduardo Sanchez produced by Greg Hale
and Robin Cowie
[Applause]
let's see you that directed by David
Riker
[Music]
produced by David Riker and Paul s
messin you should stay in the city
shelters that's what they're there for
everybody second each other I never took
my daughter to the junkie someone who
loves his daughters so much would take
the dirt off her face
compensation directed by Xena boo Irene
Davis produced by zainabou Irene Davis
and Mark Arthur Sheree
my dearest Melinda you have opened my
eyes on to a new world full of
possibilities full of hope and promise I
would have liked it in your hearing
voice in the world
[Applause]
Judy Berlin directed by Erich Mendelsohn
produced by Rocco Caruso
[Applause]
[Music]
and Treasure Island directed by Scott
King produced by Adrienne Grubin big
mouth Junko Dear John I've been putting
off this letter for months and I think
it's better if I just say see Dear John
I think he's named Jeff and the Spirit
Award goes to the Blair Witch Project
[Applause]
[Music]
it's really an honor to win this it's
been an incredible year for us we're
really lucky guys way too many people
contributed this to for in Stephen to
start the many people individually most
of those people that helped us out are
in this room thank you especially Kevin
Fox our executive producer we did want
to point out though that the guys in the
movie really were acting so we kind of
like to dedicate this award to Heather
Mike and Josh we think they kind of got
swept aside and the whole phenomenon in
the film which is really great for us
but hopefully you other filmmakers out
there will remember that these guys
really are actors and help them out so
thanks a lot
[Applause]
People magazine gave me this camera
because they thought I could maybe help
document the day so could you all lean
in a little bit all right
smile smile great I'm gonna call it a
view from the podium all right our next
presenters are for the Motorola
producers award he makes movies about
cross dressers she's the star of Beverly
Hills 90210 please welcome John Waters
and Hilary Swank
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you you must be having a
relaxing little weekend I'm always
worrying just that I've got a Rossi
Award nomination I can't imagine what
you're going through okay oh this is my
turn to talk right
while actors and directors generally get
the acclaim when an indie is successful
one of the main contributors is often
overlooked the producer the Motorola
producers award was created to honor
these resilient creative people who
managed with limited resources to tell
the kinds of stories that are rarely
seen in mainstream movies and how
appropriate that a producer's award
would be sponsored by a cell phone
company besides a free phone the
Motorola producer award comes with an
unrestricted grant of $20,000 funded by
Motorola
plus a 1995 headset so they don't have
to blow the 20 grand on chemo
the finalists for the motor role the
producers award our love that will wait
good writers we have a Pam Koffler
producer of I'm losing you an office
killer
Ivica Lautner producer of boys don't cry
and hide-and-seek
Paul s was a producer of la ciudad and
christine walker producer of backroads
and homo height
and the Motorola producer award goes to
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much to the IFP
West for this award sauna and to
Motorola for sponsoring this incredibly
generous award this prize must be shared
with a number of people the team at
killer films I can't say enough about
them
Katy Rimmel Brad Simpson Laird Adams and
John Marcus Jocelyn Hayes and Ian brick
you all worked so hard you create
miracles on a daily basis I really adore
you
Christine Bosch on my producing partner
and friends dear friends who isn't here
today
Christine we miss sharing all this with
you so much we're thinking about you all
the time I was lucky enough to get a
call from Christine a lot of years ago
to work on a movie with her and she
literally quoted the fee as chump change
I know it's an indie film cliche but
it's true and thankfully I took her up
on it and I knew the minute I walked
into that office I would never leave and
I didn't and several years later we
formed killer films together and several
films later here we are
producing movies as everyone here knows
is an imbalanced equation of pleasure
and pain but when the rewards come they
are so incredibly powerful and and deep
and I'm very very grateful to the
directors I've been allowed to
collaborate with and support and
experience the important process of
telling a story that matters in a
provocative and original way that
hopefully is meaningful to people I feel
really lucky to have had a part in all
of the films I've worked on I'm really
proud of them all mom and dad thanks for
being here today
thank you to my husband Russell for
being everything all the time and to Kim
khloé Hillary and Andy all the boys
don't cry team you deserve the stars in
the moon this weekend we're so so proud
thank you very very much
we felt bad that we couldn't get every
movie in the anniversary clip real since
there were over 350 of them and then
Diane came up with the idea to honor
these 15 years of nominated films by
naming them all and we found just the
person to do it
take it away John 28 updating for
Charlie Moffat a great world the
addiction affliction After Hours
afterglow all over me all the premieres
of New York American hardening to let my
table Anna the Apostle the baby dance
bad lieutenant back down here baby
Belgium for the Battle of Little Joe
bang Barcelona barfly Basquiat the beans
indeed remain before the rain Bella's
are the Cajun Billy bestseller the Bible
gun club the Big Easy big night black
rain blessing blind faith not simple
blue kite blue velvet Boca Boca the
boost aboard a radio band box and was
named Vincent reeking the waste writing
this could take a while maybe we'll get
back to him later thank you John thank
you we'll come back to you thank you
thank you John thank you like my
ex-husband he never shuts up okay I
didn't mean that my ex-husband is
actually backstage helping me write
jokes that I desperately need so you may
have noticed our fabulous set it has
names painted on it of former nominees
for example the Bad Lieutenant I'm sure
everybody remembers that one Harvey
Keitel was in it he had that scene you
know the Apostle who can forget the
thrill ride that was the Apostle and
over here we have what The Grifters
remember naked mrs. Warren Beatty and
underneath we have one of my favorite
films I shot any Warhol well I guess if
you can't shoot Andy Warhol any Warhol
will do I think we should probably get
back to our presenters our next
presenter previously won a Spirit Award
for passion fishing she was nominated
last year for down in the Delta and our
other presenter recently completed
filming the guilty and he helped save
the world and Independence Day
which ironically was not an independent
movie
please welcome alfre woodard and Bill
Pullman
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you we're here to present the
spirit award for the best first feature
over $500,000 and these are unique and
creative stories told the by determined
filmmakers who didn't compromise so
Alfre and I are wondering how would they
get the five hundred thousand if they
didn't do that okay imagine going in to
sell okay
and out-of-work puppeteer finds a portal
into John Malkovich is brain you know
that somebody said it's gonna take five
hundred thousand dollars to build John
Malkovich is brain ok sell this Siamese
twins one of whom is dying of organ
failure like alright some of the organs
are doing very well though right and we
see some of that you know that's some of
them ok ok here's the pitch
experiencing the struggles of post-war
Vietnam against Western corruption as
seen through the eyes of four different
characters right well I have a problem
with this too because I always thought
that VC stood for Vietcong but now it's
venture capitalists oh the amazing
journey of a young woman searching for
identity by posing as a boy in the
hardscrabble loneliness of rural
Nebraska I like that I think that makes
a good movie but you know somebody said
it's got to be set in the strip club in
Miami
here's the story we got a 12 year old
girl sent away from our family trade sex
in hopes of returning home that sounds
like a movie but can we go younger that
it was very bad our hats are off to the
people who found the money and who put
up the money for these remake remarkable
stories and the nominees for the best
first feature over $500,000 are being
John Malkovich directed by Spike Jonze
and produced by Michael Stipe sandy
Stern Steve Golan and Vincent land a
with all due respect I discovered that
portal I mean it's my livelihood
understand it's my head it's my head I
will see you in court
boys don't cry directed by kimberly
peirce and produced by jeffrey sharp
john hart
viva collage nur and christine bestial
let me look at your line I can't believe
you got a model for a sister like a
little movie star yourself three seasons
directed by Tony Bowie and produced by
Jason Cleo Cleo and Johanna Vincent a
and Tony boy
[Applause]
[Music]
TWEN Falls Idaho directed by Michael
polish and produced by Marshall
Persinger Rena Ronson and Steven J Wolfe
[Applause]
[Music]
show show the sent down girl directed by
Joan Chen and produced by Joan Chen and
Alice Chan
[Applause]
[Music]
and the spirit award goes to Being John
Malkovich
convincing day
[Music]
the the Charlie Kaufman I was up here a
little while ago and he thanked pretty
much everyone we needed to thank except
himself which we owe this all to and so
I just want to thank Charlie Kaufman and
the these guys up here who somehow got
this movie made Michael Stipe in slam
day Steve Golan and sandy Stern I was
cleaning out my desk this week and I
found this which was faxed to me and
it's coverage on the script from a
studio I did not write this Charlie
Kaufman did not write this comments it
becomes obvious early on that this is
not just another delusional puppeteer
cheating on his wife who marries a
monkey hell-bent on greatness by
entering the body of John Malkovich
time-traveling good-versus-evil arcane
Cultus rule and the world morality tale
slash love story no it's much more than
that
it probably would be held as an inspired
piece of work on the planet on which it
was written unfortunately
unfortunately I did not have sufficient
quantities of the medication necessary
to allow this story to make sense to me
without going into too much detail I can
all honestly admit that I didn't get it
and doubt that anyone else will and had
the feeling of an avant-garde Broadway
play which might appeal to the audience
of no more than twenty at a time
script pass writer pass Thank You IFP
it's time to introduce our Best
Screenplay presenters
she made leg braces look sexy and crash
he made Helen Hunt look sexy in the
water dance
please welcome Rosanna Arquette and Eric
salts
[Applause]
[Music]
hi we're here to present the Award for
Best Screenplay the nominees for Best
Screenplay are Kevin Smith for dogmas
Alexander Payne and Jim Taylor for
election
Audrey wet audrey wells for Guinevere
LEM Dobbs for the limey
James Maron Dino for SLC punk and the
spirit award goes to Alexander Payne
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Jim that's Alexander thank you very
much well we want to thank first the
nominating committee because we're very
honored to be even be included on the on
the ballot here and especially in this
context it means a lot to us to been
honored by the Independent Spirit Awards
when in fact we worked with some very
supportive people at MTV Films and at
Paramount Studios they actually let us
make this film so know which is
something because I mean it's
unfortunate that we have this perceived
cleft between commercial American cinema
and independent or more a tourist cinema
and it's just nice when as historically
it has up until the 80s that they were
it was often one in the same so it's
just nice that were being able to do
what we do at a studio the this was
screenplay was adapted from a novel by
Tom parada is fine so we owe a great
deal to Tom for these characters in
situations just a wonderful gift his
book let's be brief right next we share
this with Ron York's and Albert Berger
who sent us the book on the heels of
we want the heels of citizen Ruth sent
us that book which actually I didn't
even read for a while because it was set
in a high school I wasn't so interested
in high school but I finally read it at
their nudging and enjoyed it very much
parent of Paramount Pictures Sherry
Lansing
Michelle Manning Dede Gardner John
Goldwyn all great advocates of the film
MTV Films van Toffler David gale Lisa
Coppola vets at Paramount I already said
that oh you did I'm sorry I spaced out I
was just thinking about these things
we're ready bombing here I know I
thought these were to deflect bullets or
something but there are cast for
speaking our words in such dulcet tones
yes Matthew Broderick and Reese
Witherspoon fantastic and Jessica
Campbell is here
so thank you very much
because I forgot someone what the hell
all right
we all know there's a big difference
between how you work a major motion
picture premiere and how you work an
indie premiere first off at a major
premiere if you want to get an Oscar in
style what you do you find the biggest
star you can you get up right close to
him
better yet you put your arm around him
that way you can't be cut out
people would say whose fingers are those
but at an indie premiere if anybody asks
you're not there to have your picture
taken think of a cooler reason say I
went to college with the DP and if you
want to get in the hip magazines like
paper or flaunt you really have to stand
up to meet next to these two guys please
welcome Steve Buscemi and Peter stormer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
would it kill you to say something nice
on my anecdote we had a script but we
obviously we we we're not using it I
just I want to apologize to Hilary Swank
I I met you before and I wasn't sure it
was you and and you said that she loved
my work and all I said view was
congratulations because I figured that
was the safest thing to say to somebody
here but I did see the movie and I do
love you work but I don't feel so bad
because you said to me then you were so
happy you were presenting with me
and I said we are and he said oh no
that's John Waters
[Applause]
who goes first we should just do this
the nominations for Best Supporting I
mean the nominations for Best Supporting
male are Charles s Dutton for a cookies
fortune
Clark great The Adventures of Sebastian
Cole Louise husband for the limey
Terrence Howard for the best man and
Steve Zahn for happy Texas
and the spirit award goes to Steve Zahn
for happy Tector
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
okay then it goes to Steve Buscemi
[Applause]
our keynote speaker this year is one of
the most successful forces and
independent films today good machine the
company he formed along with his partner
Ted Hope has also been responsible for
discovering and nurturing some of the
strongest voices in independent cinema
directors like Angley and Todd Salons
among them in fact good machine even
started its own distribution company so
happiness wouldn't be put on the shelf
James is also a gifted writer who has
written or collaborated on such films as
the wedding banquet eat drink man women
know eat drink man woman there's only
one woman it's an art piece and the ice
storm he's executive produced dozens
more including walking and talking safe
Sense and Sensibility and the brothers
McMullen in addition he has been
involved in four of the past nine grand
jury prizes at Sundance so he's a good
person to know all that and he knows to
tie how to tie one mean bowtie please
welcome this year's keynote speaker
James Shamus
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry I didn't pack the boats I didn't
realize was such a stick but but it's
there hold on I've got something else
important to put on this table thank you
so much for having 15 years of
Independent Spirit Awards and the main
question that faces me of course is how
could they not find somebody famous to
give this speech but it's my problem of
course and I've been studying a lot of
the prior speeches from you know the
years past Francis Ford Coppola and Mike
Lee and all these kind of famous guys
and one thing I've learned is that I'm
going to make a pledge to you right now
that I promise not to go on as long as
Mike Lee I'm sorry Mike oh my god it's
like life is sweet but it's a short and
but the good news was that his speech
was such that it really made Ally Sheedy
look like the soul of brevity and
there's a good there's a silver lining
to every class and of course they're
bringing Ally Sheedy back that's a good
thing but I also realized that I
actually had because I'm not famous
famous people to get up there and they
very emotive they're kind of squeezing
the onion thing like you're independent
and I'm so inspired by you and you're so
inspired by me because I'm so famous and
rich and we're all so inspired by each
other but I can't do that so because you
just wouldn't take that crap from me so
I'm gonna try to say something and have
an actual argument here today and at the
end of my argument will actually take a
vote and you can tell me whether or not
you agree with the argument and the
argument is ghosts like this I'm going
to move by popular acclaim or not that
we you're so inspired by me because I'm
so famous and rich and we're also
inspired by each other but I can't do
that so because you just wouldn't take
that crap from me so I'm going to try to
say something and have an actual
argument here today and at the end of my
argument will actually take a vote and
you can tell me whether or not you agree
with the argument and the argument is
ghosts like this I'm going to move by
popular acclaim or not that we
immediately dissolve the independent
feature project and cancel these Spirit
Awards so that's the argument and
there's a couple of points in support of
the argument that I'll make the first is
it was very simple which is that there
just too many award shows even though
the IFP or the spirit award is the
second best award it's still it's time
to kind of do that kind of unilateral
decommissioning of awards I think and so
I'll try to kind of talk about that a
little bit and then the other reason
obviously is because the IFP has
actually succeeded so remarkably in
doing what it set out to do that there's
literally no reason left for it to exist
in its current form so we can kind of
end what we started out to do right here
and kind of go out in a blaze of glory
I mentioned that the IFP award the
spirit award is the second best award
and it it is and that's a tall order I
mean when you think of all the other
awards out there you know the publicists
award and the break away from the Golden
Globes the satellite award maybe some of
you have one that's on the national
broadcast work I mean there's so many
awards out there now that it's getting
very difficult to schedule the whole
awards season thing and to give you one
idea one example of why it's become
apparent least to me that that's the
cases I just mentioned one one movie
that was involved in that kind of came
out this year called ride with the devil
and yeah is it my point exactly and it
does Hastur I mean just um but we got a
letter you know in the mail and
announcing that we had won an award from
some an organization that promotes
values like family values or values and
films and which was great we were really
excited and I turned to Aang leave the
director with this letter I said Aang
you know here's a guy here you are a guy
who has won the Golden Bear not once but
twice is won the Berlin Film Festival
twice in a career and guess what you
just won the crystal teddy award that's
like our careers I mean if the next
movie doesn't work like a footnote but
it's just gotten to the point now where
there are so many of these things
although again I do like the spirit
award and I actually wanted to ask them
to bring up the spirit award because
it's like the alternative award and I'm
gonna do a little semiotic analysis now
kind of hermeneutics of the award to
show you how politically correct and
groovy we are because as you can see
from the award unlike the other kind of
really phallic shiny naked bald penis
Awards this one is really so delicate an
alternative and non phallic and really
kind of you know it's free like a bird
independent and which is great and it
really does make it the second-best
award the first award though the best
award out there actually is the word it
was given by my guild the Writers Guild
of America we're a very macho guild as
you know and we're going on strike by
the way next year and yeah because
people don't treat us that well actually
but that's the whole other speech and
but the thing is that even for like a
Joe Eszterhas kind of guild we actually
come out with like this incredible award
it's like we call it the labia inflight
award it's it's the kind of award that
Oliver Stone it has nightmares about I
mean it's just so groovy
so we're best but an IFP second best and
that's great
one of the great highlights of my career
was many many years ago I think it was
about 20 or 30 years ago I won the
producer award here at the Spirit Awards
with my partner Ted Hub and we were very
honored in fact because the Spirit Award
was for producers at that time was named
after a gentleman named Brian Greenbaum
who had passed away of AIDS quite
recently before the award was given
remember when people used to mention
aids and warchest and he was just a
great brilliant wonderful guy and it's
but it's a sign of such great progress
of course that this year's producer
supports the motor role of producers
award and that comes with $20,000 so
Brian if you were up there listening you
owe me $20,000 but that's kind of what I
wanted to talk about in terms of where
this thing is going and where we all are
going in terms of independence and I did
a little research because I want to
share with you some facts to support
this argument and the facts get
something like this
it was interesting research I researched
all the nominees from 15 years ago and I
listed all the nominees for all the
categories and I added up their total
box-office gross from all the nominees
15 years ago the very first Spirit Award
I added up that gross and it added up to
believe it or not a whopping 20 million
dollars which is not chump change and I
was very interesting how that money was
earned so I broke it down even further
and this is kind of initiative statistic
ten million of the 20 million came from
films that were distributed and owned by
independent distribution companies that
it's a companies that were not owned
or completely affiliated with
large-scale multinational
capital-intensive global media companies
okay now if you'd fast forward to this
year's Spirit Awards this year spirit
boards I added up the total box office
for all the nominees and of course there
are fewer nominees in there's inflation
and all that kinda stuff but the total
came to 300 million dollars in box
office 300 million dollars in box office
I know it's incredible two hundred and
ninety nine point nine eight million of
which was earned by companies owned or
affiliated with large-scale global
multinational capital intensive
corporations three hundred million two
hundred and ninety nine point nine eight
now some people I know will argue that
artisan that feisty upstart which gave
us Blair which which counts for a big
chunk of this is not owned by a
corporate media type but I did something
cool I went on the internet and I
brought down a press release that was
issued by Bain Capital bain capital
controls artisan and this is kind of
interesting and this is great they're
great listen this here's what they say
they say they currently manage more than
seven billion dollars and that they have
quote taken over twenty companies public
with a combined current market
capitalization exceeding twenty four
billion dollars so let's hear it for
little guys
you know all the people out in the
parking lot running around in circles
that's all the artisan guys doing like
Indian dances around there SCC public
filings you know they're going like
Harvey has Disney stock but we have an
IPO which is great so the question I
post to all of us is why at these awards
should we at this point be pretending to
storm the castle when in fact we're
inside the castle with the buckets of
hot tar keeping everybody else out but
that does leave us in terms of these
award shows and this one in particular
is a sentiment that I'm completely at
one with which is the sentiment that's
been expressed so well by Dawn and the
other people here which is that we like
movies that have something to say and we
like people who have something to say we
want to fight to preserve that my
question is maybe what we should be
doing at that point then given the
current status of our economic situation
is worrying not so much about
independent films here at the IFP and
the spirit words but actually worrying a
little bit about independence itself and
the freedom of expression and
articulation that one assumes would go
with that and what I mean is the
following maybe what we should do is
kind of dismantle what has now become
such a true success at the height of its
glory and think about what a newly
reconfigured organization would actually
conceive and do with all the spare time
we'd have after we didn't have an IFP
anymore but we had a new IFP because
there are a few things that I think
should probably worry us as we live in
what was concurrently oh I would call
our our current particular hog heaven
which someday soon may end up being
coming to a kind of non kosher
termination if we chart the current
changes in the media business in
particular what are this of these
changes that we should be worried about
well right now in Congress although you
haven't been reading about much there's
a series of hearings going on about the
AOL Time Warner merger remember the
biggest deal in the history of mankind
the AOL Time Warner merger
puts together two companies that will do
something kind of interesting if you're
interesting the internet and all that
stuff and media and all these things it
will allow a company that is basically
rooted in cable which as you know is a
monopoly right when's the last time you
turned on your TV and said you know I
should go try to shop for that other
cable company that gives me an HBO so
much cheaper it doesn't happen because
it's a monopoly and we'll put the
Internet into that monopoly right so
which is a great idea for for business
and maybe not such a good idea for those
of us who want to survive in a
marketplace of ideas where the internet
kind of says let's be free and talk to
each other and not get charged a billion
dollars for the other stuff you might
want to consider all the stuff that was
happening in Seattle a lot of that went
underground of that that we don't
consider here had to do with
intellectual property rights and in
particular the the the work of people
like Jack Valenti who's doing a great
job on so many things
to kind of destroy all the European and
other international media companies out
there in the rest of the world but we as
independents really rely on the
independence of all these other
countries to buy our films once those
companies disappear as they are quickly
doing now we're really going to be more
or less left hung out to dry so it's a
kind of good idea to try to kind of
chart this stuff and all that kind of
way finally the Telecommunications Act
96 I know you guys are so excited about
that when it happened I've been charting
and talking about it ever since it did
by the way unbeknownst and most of us
give away 15 billion dollars of spectrum
on the airwaves just literally gave it
away to all the companies that by the
way take in about a billion dollars
every election in advertising revenues
from politicians so it's the kind of
thing that has accelerated all these
mergers and we should probably be
organizing against I won't do too much
more political stuff except to say that
unless we ourselves start to think about
these things a little bit more
particularly we're probably not gonna be
having too many more Independent Spirit
Awards in 5-10 years or if we do they'll
have like Debbie Allen choreography and
stuff and only will be hard to kind of
pretend that just because we're in a
tent that were quite different from what
else is going on out there if you think
I'm being paranoid and boring and
political that's fine but I just want to
end with the quotation from Gerald Levin
who's this kind of wonderful visionary
genius yeah at Time Warner and here's
what here's what your old Levin said a
couple months ago right before the AOL
merger he said the following global
media companies are and I quote more
important than government we're going to
have to have these corporations
redefined because they have the
resources they have the reach they have
the skill base and that may be a more
efficient way to deal
society's problems than bureaucratic
governments end quote I kid you can't
make the up and but it's kind of
coming on the one hand is very cool
because they really believe this on the
other hand it's not so cool because it
may end up being true at which point you
know like when you're born you won't get
it like a voting share of class a AOL
stock and that will be your Buy and to
the whatever's left of public discourse
is available to you so we as independent
filmmakers I think and independent media
makers might want to consider ourselves
as independent people too
and try to be somewhat in the forefront
of the organizing around these issues
even as of course our corporate you know
trough that we feed at makes our
livelihoods more and more possible to us
these days I would suggest therefore
that we go back to our beginnings and
think about how it is that we can begin
anew create a new institution that might
possibly rest on the laurels of this one
and go forward with that
I'm going to wrap it up because I'm have
done my little political thing and with
many apologies to Michael II put that
crack at the beginning of my speech by
the way if you haven't seen Mike Lee's
latest film it's wonderful topsy turvy
it's three hours long but it's great so
I hope you guys are well take care of
okay I don't want to say Ally Sheedy so
I'm gonna whisper it
James I don't know if you know but while
you were talking they were cutting to
every attractive babe in the audience
okay just so you don't have any
surprises when you go home and watch it
on TV one other thing when I said he was
wearing a bow tie I said why am I saying
this they said that's his trademark
everywhere he goes he wears a bow tie
when you see a bow tie you think James
Sheamus and then he didn't wear a bow
tie so I just wanted to explain that
part of the introduction okay halfway
point loosen up don't eat the fish
anymore because you know it's been
sitting here in the heat and we don't
want to get sued here at the Spirit
Awards okay now to present the award for
Best Supporting female are two of the
performers from the movie lone star one
previously received this award and the
other plays an ex-marine Colonel and
American Beauty I'll let you figure out
which one is which
here's Elizabeth Pena and nobody's
favorite next-door neighbor Chris Cooper
[Music]
[Applause]
you know Chris you know what's really
really great about being a supporting
actor you don't get to carry the movie
yeah you don't have to get pumped up you
don't have to carry around who's these
either
Oh Oh Izzy's explosion especially
affects your thinking studio films where
they pay you but these are the
independent films yeah so the nominees
are Barbara Barrie for Judy Berlin
Vanessa Martinez for limbo Sarah Polley
for go Chloe Sevigny
for boys don't cry
and gene smart for Guinevere
[Applause]
khloe's seven
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow I'm so honored thank you all so very
very much and I like to thank everybody
involved in this movie which means so
much to me everyone a killer and
everyone at Fox and the independent film
channel so thank you all so very much
okay I rehearse but I didn't rehearse
with Chloe okay
our next presenters Peter Fonda hope
someday somebody will make a documentary
about his life so he can see all the
parts he missed back in the 70s
his Co presenter Denise Richards saved
the world in the last James Bond film by
wearing hot pants
in fact she saved the movie please
welcome Peter Fonda and Denise Richards
[Music]
[Applause]
four years ago IFP West created a
special award to honor the most
independent of independent filmmakers
the documentary filmmaker the DJ LDL J
direct sure that I know I said I would
do that the DL J truer than fiction
award is presented to an emerging
documentary filmmaker of unique vision
and talent who has not yet received
snippet significant attention the ward
is accompanied by a $20,000 use that a
twenty thousand dollar unrestricted
grant funded by DL J direct to help
further them in their career whoa I'm
going back to the color I do remember
the sixties I'm 16 I'm right in there
the finalists for this year's DL J
director truer than fiction award our
night waltz the music of Paul Bowles
directed by obviously Brown
on the ropes
directed by net Nanette Burstein and
Brett Morgan well-founded fear directed
by Michael Camarena
and sherry Robertson and American Hollow
directed by Rory Kennedy and ensure that
fiction award goes to does it but I love
owls Lee brown the night walls and music
of Paul Bowles
[Applause]
[Music]
totally unbelievable to be here in front
of all of you all and to receive this
award and so thanks very much to the
people who gave the film the award and
thanks very much to all the people who
helped this film come to life
specifically the people in the beginning
who believed in the project the film's
producer Robin Burke and Cynthia gimble
and Danza Mandell and then the film's
DPS David Golia
Nick Dorsky gene Sala Torre and also a
legendary filmmaker who gave me three of
his films to include in this film Rudy
Burkhart and a special thanks to Nick
who was the film's editor and gave a
sensibility to this film that I think
really does represent something
independent and for me gave the film its
its its life and to my family of course
my two children my wife my parents my
grandmother who was particularly helpful
when cash was low and I think I guess
then to one last person before thanking
Paul Philip Raimi who gave me the
connection I needed to make the film
about Paul and then to Paul who died in
November and who made sure that this was
a film he approved of and he did approve
of it before he died and so this is for
Paul Bowles thanks very much
I think we should play strip Spirit
Awards everybody remove an article of
clothing every ten minutes
and let's see if we're all naked by the
time the show is over I'm just saying
that because it's hot in here okay David
O'Russell he's won two Independent
Spirit Awards he spanked the monkey he's
flirted with disaster and he made Spike
Jonze pull a map out of an Iraqi
soldiers ass and three kings please give
him a big welcome because he deserves it
here's David all ruffles
[Applause]
[Music]
they forgot this I've been asked to
clarify the process by which the IFP
chooses its nominees each year most
people are aware that the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences relies
on the accounting firm of Price
Waterhouse to assist them in this
extremely rigorous system of nominations
everybody thinks that such that no such
mathematically precise method could
possibly be used here especially for the
elusive task of defining what qualifies
as an independent film everybody is dead
wrong the IFP uses the scientifically
proven indie scale which you'll see on
either screen here which quickly
separates the wheat from the chaff by
fitting a film into a simple grid and
point system I look down the vertical
axis shows the root components of
independent cinema family dysfunction
drugs rural life homosexuality skewed
romantic comedy a straight up the middle
story of redemption and bad writing the
horizontal axis covers murder strange
violence esoteric concepts ethnic
subculture sexual dysfunction and
Miramax so to show you how it works you
take family dysfunction with a value of
seven points and sexual dysfunction with
a value of five points you multiply and
that gives you a point total of 35 this
is the zone of such movies as happiness
or the house of yes or spanking the
monkey those are nominees those were
nominees rural life homosexuality and
strange violence would give you 35
points and such nominees as boys don't
cry my own private Idaho while murder
and homosexuality would give you swoon
and heavenly creatures so maybe you're
starting to get a feel for this now
please note the straight up story the
straight up the middle story of
redemption like Good Will Hunting only
Garner's enough points if distributed by
Miramax straight
straight story the straight story is an
exception but it is distributed by
Disney which owns Miramax now some have
protested that this gridpoint system is
too restrictive and goes against the
independent spirit of defying genre and
category it's just not inclusive enough
they say well the IFP has thoughtfully
addressed this problem by expanding the
nominating process with turbo indie
scale on the vertical axis we have
scripts based on math equations letting
movie stars play themselves folding the
process of moviemaking back on itself by
deconstructing the movie process in the
movie foot held camera why not once then
70s TV stars that are now fat on the
horizontal axis we have talking objects
finger puppets 100% voiceover no
dialogue ethnic subculture family
dysfunction and Miramax once again those
three okay so you can see how truly
democratic and inclusive this process is
but is it precise yes mathematically
precise once the nominees are weeded out
by the grid point system they are boiled
down to an elite group using this
equation provided by UCLA Nobel
laureates you plug in your values and
them do the math and you get your final
nominees I apologize if I've taken some
of the mystery out of suspense out of
this awards process but that is what I
was asked to do thank you very much
okay they should have somebody come
clear this away it's been sitting here
for about ten minutes now all right I
had an incredible menage tois with our
next two presenters she made love to me
while he watched on a crane please
welcome the cinematographer abound and
the girl who tried to steal all my
scenes from me bill Pope and Gina
Gershon
[Applause]
try to steal Jennifer scenes good luck
a talented director of photography can
quickly become a girl's best friend they
could literally make or break your
career and you know besides kind of
being the coolest people on the set no
that's true if they make you look
fantastic
you love them and for that reason bill
Pope I will always love you you you
truly you made me look amazing I love
you
thank you very much dude thank you thank
you it's really quite simple I mean we
were the simplest of all I have to do is
sort of remove those dark circles
sometimes and kind of straighten out the
nose every now and then maybe sometimes
the double chin after a few weeks of
craft service really you bill can't
we just go right to it oh yeah no okay
no the nominees is there two Woot's
everywhere the nominees for Best
Cinematography are Harlan Baz Magian for
la ciudad
[Music]
daaad mantle for Julian donkey boy em
David Mullen for Twin Falls Idaho
Lisa Rentschler for three seasons and
Jeffrey second door for court Judy
Berlin and the award goes to you want to
do this bill since this is your these
are your people
I've had enough bad acting for today you
did great
you know a new career for Bill you can
get him to act and shoot it Lisa
Rinzler for three seasons
[Music]
[Applause]
hi Lisa
thanks you she's unable to make it some
such thing this award on her behalf she
went a similar award last year at
Sundance at that time she couldn't make
it because she had she was a new mother
this year she cannot make it because
she's a mother of a one-year-old
daughter and it's great to see that she
still maintains her tours of passion and
that's her family so she'll be very
happy thank you
look what I got on eBay do you think
it'll look suspicious if I have it
engraved with Bride of Chucky
okay next to princess best foreign film
Diane Lane who is nominated today for
best female lead in a walk on the moon
and Kevin Pollak who probably also took
house arrest off his resume
please welcome Diane Lane and Kevin
Pollak
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much please be seated Diane
congratulations on your nomination thank
you they must be very exciting thank you
I have no idea what that feels like it's
just a day of seeing a lot of films I'm
not in actually there were some people
like myself who wanted to be in some of
the films nominated today I happen to
know for a fact that Alan Arkin
screen-tested four boys don't cry I
can't help myself I like girls is that
wrong I don't know they're soft and
pretty and now the nominees for that was
the ad-lib part yeah
all right the nominees for best foreign
film are all about my mother
directed by Pedro maldavar
my son the fanatic
directed by you day and Prasad Rosetta
directed by Luc and jean-pierre den Run
Lola Run director Bom Bom - and topsy
turvy directed by Mike Lee
this year's recipient is Run Lola Run
directed by Tom pike fur
[Music]
thank you very much thanks to IFP I
really want to thank people I mean
everybody who really was involved in
this film it was the greatest crew I've
ever had it was most of the people I've
worked with for the third time and we
still survived being together which is
good but there are some people I mean
major stars behind the camera I want to
point that today because they're here
and there is especially people who
created the musical score which was kind
of really important in the film and
that's Johnny climax Ronald hyre over
there I want to thank American audiences
for going into a german-speaking film so
much since seeing it for such a such an
enormous amount of time you know it ran
for like six months I want to thank
those people who made it possible that
it went so big in America and that is
Sony Pictures Classics especially
Michael and Tom my coworker Tom Barnard
thanks a lot for all this was amazing
work and one person have to think was in
front of the camera who's my absolute
favorite actress in the entire world and
that's Lola and she's called franka
potente
thanks to you
I like that director it can take
direction did you see that I pointed and
he went that way
all right the new president of IFP West
is an actual recognize from his
appearances in Chicago hope Crooklyn and
ease by you he's also the president of
motor city films and the writer director
the independent feature gridlock which I
was up for but sadly I did not get two
nights ago he graciously entertained the
nominees at a cocktail party at his
house which is precariously balanced on
a cliff in the middle of nowhere some of
the nominees never even made it back
down the hill please welcome the new
president of IFP West Bundy Curtis Hall
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you I am very honored to stand
before you as a new board president but
I must say that I wouldn't be here
without the support of our former
president Barbara Boyle and our
executive director Don Hudson my deepest
thanks to both of you however my
presidential duties thus far have mainly
been fielding tickets for the Spirit
Awards seems like my old friends are
calling from nowhere going hey body
congratulations man on presidency cuckoo
hooked me up with some tickets you know
so I just want you to know that this job
isn't as easy as it seems not for
everybody I'd like to introduce you now
to my partner in crime so to speak our
new executive vice president Michael
hell fan and Michael where are you just
want to various he and I are gonna have
the opportunity to implement some very
exciting programs this year all of which
were initiated under the former
administration and we will have the good
fortune of taking credit for them so
we're very very excited about that
very very excited very very excited it's
it's one of those words I never used or
one of those phrases I've never used
before I moved to Los Angeles very very
excited it seems that everyone is very
very excited I'm very excited to be here
I was very excited to be with you it's
one of those transitive verbs that a lot
of people use in this town
I'd also like to introduce you to our
other chapters eiope chapters who've all
been here for our first summit meeting
and we've taken great strides in laying
out the foundation
or a national eiope organization and
ultimately is my hope a global IFP
organization so I'd like to introduce
you to eiope Miami
I happy Minneapolis
IPE Chicago
I happy New York the first I have to I'd
like to welcome you all to Los Angeles
and to the spirit Awards and now it's
time to pass the Hat and I want you to
fill it not with money but I like you
fill it with your support for the past
seven years IFP or seven years ago I
should say I founded a program called
Project involvement
this helped increase diversity in the
film industry and nurture filmmaking
that reflects the broad spectrum of the
American society through mentorship
programs workshops on filmmaking and
film screenings project involved as
nurtured the careers of over 250 young
african-american asian-american Latino
American Native American gay and lesbian
filmmakers these filmmakers have been
placed with some of the most influential
filmmakers in the independent film world
including Allison Anders called Franklin
Charles Burnett and Casey lemons many
have gone on to work on in the industry
such as Pepe Brown mentored by producer
Lorri Parker is now a future line
producer things you can tell just by
looking at it and it's also produced
several short films including stripping
for Jesus Lady Anne hatch Sarita joe
cobb was mentored by fine line president
marco deskey and it's not working in
acquisitions at fine line and list goes
on and on I could do all I could name
all 250 of them you'd like many of these
people are these young people our
students at USC UCLA Cal arts and other
local colleges so I urge you to call us
sign up for project involved there are a
number of ways you can support and not
only will you find it personally
rewarding I'm sure that it will make a
lot of these young students
very very excited thank you
now I'd like to introduce a pair of
performance who have been nominated for
virtually every kind of film award there
there is you may remember them as Maude
and as the dude here are do you learn
more and Jeff Bridges
[Music]
good afternoon the nominees for best
male lead are John Cusack for being John
Malkovich
Richard Farnsworth for the straight
story
parents damn for the lyonie
David Strathairn for limbo
and Noble Willingham for the corndog man
and the Spirit Award goes to Richard
Barnes
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all so much my agent I am
David said there be a lot of offers
coming through after they seen this
picture I did get one they need a dialog
coats for bottles and James I'm gonna
take that of course Mary Sweeney and
John Roach wrote this story it's it's
true and I had a great time making it
and of course
David Lynch bless his heart he was so
good with me this is quite a little bit
different for his kind of movies but he
has tickle me to death and I found he
was directing this and I I hope this
might set a trend for maybe some older
guys getting to work in the films a
little it seemed like it's mostly good
when I get my hip replacement from Santa
Barbara next month I'm and you're back
riding the horse on the ranch I'll be
thinking about you back thank you so
much
and now to present the award for best
female lead is a man who was nominated
for a Golden Globe and Emmy and the Los
Angeles Film Critics Award for Best
Supporting Actor but more importantly he
survived a ladies acceptance speech last
year which took longer than a lawnmower
ride across Iowa that was just
coincidental please welcome John Don
Cheadle
[Music]
[Applause]
hey I was supposed to present this award
today with Ally Sheedy but she wasn't
able to well she said she was unable to
make it so she taped her speech and I
would just we're gonna bring it out and
let her go ahead and put it on no that's
take it sorry let's just get to the
names okay the nominees for best female
lead are Diane Lane for walk on the moon
Janet McTeer for tumbleweeds
Hilary Swank her boys don't cry
Susan trailer for Valerie plague
reese witherspoon for election
and the spirit award goes to huh Hilary
Swank
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much
what an amazing support thank you
[Music]
Wow it's either an echo or there's some
more support out there um you know I
know Ally speech I guess was long last
year and mine's gonna be long too and
you guys might all make fun of me and
have some cassettes pulled up next year
and all that but it's just you know it
may be once-in-a-lifetime thing and I'm
gonna talk you know I think what's quite
extraordinary this is really an even
more exciting honor because everyone in
this room understands what it's like to
give your heart and soul to something
without getting paid a dime and to put
everything into it so congratulations to
all of you you know this movie three and
a half years ago no one would make it
and I think that that is a sad comment
on society yet it got made and so that's
even I think a better comment for
society so I want to thank Kim Peirce
for fighting like hell having the
tenacity
the fierce drive and just the unending
press of variants to get this movie made
christine vishawn Ivica Lautner pam
Koffler at killer films everyone at
killer films for her also believing in
the movie jeff sharp john hart for being
just so supportive of this whole process
and me being there for me every single
day
chloë Sevigny my beautiful co-star the
whole cast who was so just brilliantly
pro-trade their characters so honestly
and it was just beautiful my husband
over there Chad Lowe who without him I
could have never made it through this
whole process the independent film
channel for coming in and giving us some
money to finish our movie
and Michaels Dremel Lindsey law everyone
at Fox for taking this small movie and
giving it a home in theaters for the
whole world to see
thank you very much gosh Andy Beeman our
co-writer and I I am I think that I want
to thank the person who has the the
biggest independent spirit brandon teena
lived his life the way he wanted to
follow it his heart didn't conform in
the independent spirit way and I think
it's an inspiration for all of us and
through this movie Brandon's spirit
lives on and and that's quite an honor
so thank you very much for this
I met Hillary before she was famous she
was kicking the back of my seat at a
premier one night
that's my celebrity story and I'm proud
of it
everywhere I go people say how do you do
it Jennifer how do you come up with
these porn titles every year and more
importantly would you stop well it's
easy and I'm gonna teach you how to do
it so you can do it in the comfort and
privacy of your own home all you do is
you rearrange a few words for example
instead of go-come instead of election
erection and then there's Angela's asses
Felicia's horny Twin Falls I'm a ho and
the not so straight story good you
didn't laugh because you see what I'm
doing up here is I'm practicing tantric
comedy I'm saving that laugh in case I
need it later on our next category is
the move artist someone to watch award
our presenters start to gather in
American Beauty a film that has done
more for roses than 1-800 flowers here
is wes Bentley and mena Suvari
[Music]
[Applause]
each year since 1995 IFP West has given
the Movado someone to watch award to a
talented filmmaker of singular vision
who has not been appropriately
recognized the recipient will receive an
unrestricted grant of $20,000 funded by
movado watch the winner is someone whose
career we will follow who is richly
deserving of our scrutiny whose talent
we will be keeping a close eye on we
guarantee that we'll always be there
close by
watching and watching and watching the
finalists for the Movado someone to
watch awards are Dan Clark director of
the item
Julian Goldberger director of trends'
lisanne skyler director of getting to
know you
Colleen Smith director of dry lung so
[Music]
and the Movado someone to watch award
goes to
Colleen Smith
[Applause]
[Music]
independent spirit I wanted to make all
these witty puns about someone to watch
and you know what time it is and watch
out and I won't do that I just want to
thank Sony mcil and his family I want to
thank my family I want to thank Neil
Friedman who believed in this film
before anybody Jodie Peikoff and leek
Hill as well and Wow a huge cadre of
friends and I want to thank the City of
Oakland West Oakland and Magnolia Street
in particular for embracing us and this
movie thank you very much
here to hound out the Award for Best
Director our two great directors
themselves she won the award for
directing ramblin rose and recently
directed Chloe Sevigny and if these
walls could talk - did I say that right
Chloe where are you okay Chloe civilian
if these walls could talk - he is a
director of Waiting to Exhale and hope
floats please welcome Martha Coolidge
and the ghost dog himself Forrest
Whitaker
[Applause]
[Music]
I just wanted to say that it's
incredible to be here and look out at
you all because this is so big that's
basic celebrations for you and I was one
of those struggling isolated independent
filmmakers that got the idea of starting
the IFP many years ago and I got to tell
you something as an independent
filmmaker still it doesn't change so
this is great so one of the best things
about independent film is that it gives
people a chance to direct who might not
get that opportunity in the mainstream
in other cases it gives established
directors an outlet to work that they
never would have gotten in the studio
system and tonight we honor the five
filmmakers who run the gamut from
legendary to just getting started and
those nominees are Harmony Korine for
Julianne donkey boy
doug liman or go
David Lynch for the straight story
Alexander Payne for election
and Stephen sub soda bird for the limey
when the spirit award goes to Alexander
Payne correct
[Applause]
[Music]
you know
Wow thank you thank you look I am NOT a
better director than David Lynch or
Steven Soderbergh thank you thank you
this is great I share this very much
with my creative team whom I've worked
with before and whom I will continue
work working with James Stewart
production designer Jim Taylor my
co-writer Jim Glenn and DP Kevin 10th
editor Ralph Kent composer and Wow
thank you I thought of a couple things
to say but I can't remember them now but
I will say this just continuing my
thought from the screenplay part I saw
Erin Brockovich this week and I don't
have Soderbergh here I haven't seen it
but I called him up afterwards anyway
the point is that finally there's a
commercial American film which is also a
tourist and rather than independent
because it has all sorts of financial
connotations I like to think of it you
know the pretentious were not tourists
but regardless of where the money comes
from if we're getting it from a
consortium of dentists or from a studio
you know Martin Scorsese makes 50
million dollar independent films for
studios so it's not really about our
sources of financing I'll take money
from anywhere I don't care but what
we're talking about is that spirit that
an authorial voice comes through and yes
I have a team film is collaborative and
all that kind of stuff but that it's you
know and we always need popcorn movies
and they have their place but I sin
a'mma has to have more a sense of film
as a medium of personal artistic
expression and
and that's why I think independent
spirit is the is a very appropriate
title for this thing because it's a
spirit of Independence and it's a spirit
of authorial voice in the cinema and
that our cinema can be a mirror of our
society and not just a form of escapism
and that people can have their voices
heard for better or worse okay that's
enough of my soapbox Jim and I forgot to
mention heat samples in Jim Burke also
producers on the film thank you
I just realized I walked past all the
winners and probably anyway okay here
our last two presenters you know them
you love them you fear them mr. white
and mr. brown
[Music]
so what do you think nominations or
strain comedy actually you know I think
I think they wanted me and Harvey here
to make a big statement about the 15
years of the IFP and independent film in
general I actually think that statement
can maybe be better make by if there's a
cameraman here who's shooting in us as
the director I am asking now that
cameraman to scan the audience as I'm
talking all right right here in this
audience is independent filmmaking in
the 90s as far as I know because I've
been involved with it in 92 alright is
pretty much everybody here everybody
whatever's here in 92
alright was here and there's more people
here and I think that's all we have to
say about independent cinema in the 90s
is your faces now the nominees for Best
Feature Oh cookie fortune produced by
Robert Altman and Eddie Stroh
[Applause]
[Music]
election produced by Albert burger Ron
York sir David gale and Keith samples
the site of Tracy at that moment
affected me in a way I can't fully
explain who knew how high she would
climb in life how many people would
suffer because of her I had to stop her
now
the limey produced by John Hardy and
Scott Kramer
looks like he's broke in the every
moment you kidding extra muscle
bodyguards fellas they they parked cars
you they're having a party sugar town
produced by Danielle Hasid so what am I
supposed to wear
well you should be casual you know you
want him to be attracted to you for your
mind right not entirely right right it's
so cute it's my painting smock
no look at how cute this is like a
beatnik
the straight story produced by Mary
Sweeney and Neil it'll steam jewelry the
Bible Cain and Abel anger you mix that
together with liquor you've got two
brothers that haven't spoken in 10 years
and the spirit award goes to election
[Applause]
you know
[Music]
thank you I'm Ron York - this is my
partner Albert burger Renaissance man
keep samples in the head of MTV Films
David gale we're not thank you we're not
a full time foursome as film producers
but we enjoyed a great camaraderie and a
wonderful productive time on election we
have so many people that we'd like to
acknowledge that I think the ideas will
split it up and maybe demonstrate if we
can some of that excellent teamwork I
would like to say that one of the great
pleasures and joys I think for all of us
was how many people came up during this
last year and said they liked the film
and and really would talk at length
about it and also the beginning of this
project was kind of a producer's dream
it was an unpublished excellent
manuscript by Tom parada who
unfortunately isn't here but we'd like
to salute Tom thank you we also want to
thank Alexander and Jim for their
stellar adaptation from the moment they
came on the project they made this their
own eye we also want to thank Alexander
Payne a remarkable director who brought
the best work out from everybody in the
cast and crew this award is really a
testament to his work thank you
we were blessed with an incredible cast
led by a Matthew Broderick and Reese
Witherspoon who were incredible in the
film and complemented by Chris Klein
Jessica Campbell Marc Harlech Frankie
and Gracia Phil Ruiz and something
something that hasn't been venture very
much about election a large group of
very talented and incredibly nice high
school students in Omaha Nebraska that
helped Alexander fulfill his vision of
making this a realistic-looking high
school all of those speaking parts were
actually high school students that came
out of Omaha we also want to thank Jim
Glennon Jake Rose Jane and Stuart cannon
tent
Rolfe Kent and Wendy Chuck our
department heads who went through a
great deal to make this so realistic and
make it such a part and also to my
partner Jim Burke who like such a big
role in making this movie thank you
there was a review of election that said
I think summed it up which was a
cinematic cinematic event of great
import this the first MTV productions
film of any substance or value
whatsoever how did this happen so I just
like to thank all the people who helped
make it happen particularly people have
paramount Dede Gardner and Michelle
Manning everybody had mtv films
particularly van Toffler executive
producer of the film mo Sengupta Troy
Boone and Elise cockpits things
I don't think I was supposed to be up
here but I came anyway I already said
everything last time thank you again
thank you all those for vote who voted
for us thank you
well everybody that's our show you've
been a wonderful audience there's an
Oscar in each and every gift bag for you
goodbye
[Music]
like that clearly folks with everybody
else worked it was smooth father-son
story for my Spanish which was banking
the money spike affected her squeeze
standard which there might be starting
to step out the story issue
it created a book with street smarts
about your son basically Sweet Hereafter
sweetie swimming to Cambodia swimming
with sharks so we talked about a
strange that she would cook the piece
right there by 32 seconds like I will do
the allocation Thank You Bertram trilogy
judge perfecto dance Trainspotting
stripper catapult he's trouble in my two
stories two about twenty one twenty
bucks Twin Peaks by one who paid twister
who's gonna bearable my person being
under heaven undergraduate a new fish
with sausage vampire Castagna in 40
seconds because my way you forgot the
great abyss for walking and talking to
watch the ones after wedding back with
welcome to Davos Wes Craven to do member
sorbus what happened was we became the
whole wide world miles apart moon
subscribe like and
Zebrahead
[Music]